good evening now normally as you know i
uh
walk out and uh you know sort of
acknowledge
the scattered applause of pretty much
just andy richter in the crowd
give a little bow and then sit behind my
desk but
on nights when our guest is here in
person
we sit we start the show by sitting and
it occurs to me
it's got kind of a classy pbs look
doesn't it you just come up on me no
fanfare
no craziness i'm just sitting here
and it all feels very educational
and erudite what do you think andy yeah
you're like the trashy charlie rose
you had to bring him up sorry i think
charlie rose is the trashy charlie rose
all right well i don't even know who
charlie rose is
anymore well i'm just
saying that this looks like i'm here to
discuss
uh like public events yeah public events
yeah yeah
this looks like i'm here to talk to you
know uh a local
comptroller right about budget overruns
yeah
and flood control what's that flood
control
flood control yeah like our topic today
is flood control it doesn't have the
energy
or the feel of a dynamic comedy show
maybe it should
but i kind of like this you should
really really hit anthony anderson with
some flood control questions
i will i will i don't think anthony
anderson knows what he's in for and by
the way he is our guest today
i love him and uh maybe this setup
will lead to a more distinguished
conversation because some people have
accused
what was that noise what was that
what i heard a noise back there what was
it
i didn't i don't know was that someone's
phone
i don't know what it was was it my phone
i think it was my phone oh boy
i swear to god it was my phone you know
what and this is the thing you can say
about conan o'brien
if he's wrong he'll always refer to
himself in the third person
and he won't apologize
but that was my phone yeah
he's america's most lovable dick
america's most lovable dick that's right